he's one of the most inspirational dudes
on the planet he is a badass at light
heavyweight in the ufc he used to be a
thick boy now he's inspiring others and
doing the god damn thing it's cleo
roundtree on this week's food truck
diaries and i'm feeding them burgers
without the bun let's do it make it big
super thick from my wallet to my check i
don't want it if it's skinny but i need
it
need a
[Music]
it's exhausting you look great man
thanks man how you feeling brother i
feel good i feel good real good uh a
little bit busy but i i ask for it and i
like it busy in what way like media and
stuff uh yeah media and then i just feel
like my mind hasn't been able to shut
off because just like when when fights
are over then just like the creative
part of my mind kicks in and like what
do i want to start working on with
projects what you know i mean what
clothing design what comic book you know
just
there's a lot of projects going on so in
regards to projects when you're not
knocking dudes out with elbows and
pride style kicks and we'll get to your
fighting your last fight
outside of that you're creative dude and
we'll get them how we know each other
back in the day stuff like that but
outside of fighting like these projects
they do that's a giant bug welcome
calabasas but um
we're talking like
like what kind of creative process so
right now the main one is um
i run a brand called such limited
it used to be named super champ after an
idea and a character and a nickname that
i was given in thailand
but um the nickname was super champ
super
like super champ when i walk down the
street super champ you know and i'd be
like oh that's cool because it's because
like i was the biggest guy out there in
bangkok thailand right and they knew
that i fought and they were just like oh
a super champ there's so best nickname i
brought it over to america but it just
didn't have the same like essence that
it did in thailand like you know people
were saying like super champ and things
like that so i just reduced it down to
such su from supa ch from champ reduced
it down to such um and then i've
definitely wanted to like up the quality
so such limited because i won't really
be making many things and it's merch
merch uh community like like building a
discord community that can be in contact
with me whatever projects i have going
on
but the the overall idea is to just
create like a strong brand that i can
do
you know host skateboarding competitions
you know like do martial arts outreach
programs all types of stuff so just a
solid
my lifestyle brand yeah it's super ombre
i completely love it as far as the merch
goes what are we talking here like
streetwear uh
a mixture of like street skate and i
definitely like
you know high-end fashion and like
designer stuff but nothing too flashy i
like to keep it pretty simple so like
high quality
skate street area simple that's really
dope yeah and it's going well uh so far
so good yeah i did it i just got a just
did a rebrand um with like a new logo
and have some new
uh photographers and stuff that i'm
working with so the vision's now like
the the vision is now coming together so
yeah yeah i think uh this year by the
end of this year i think it'll be like
at a really good place and you moved to
new york yeah
i moved to new york from l.a from
thailand well so you went la right born
and raised in l.a so i was born in l.a
that's why i raised yeah born in l.a
raised in vegas moved to l.a to train at
black house that's where we met and then
i went back to vegas for a bit and then
from vegas i went to europe from europe
i went to brazil from brazil i went to
thailand and then thailand i was there
for almost three years and then i came
back to usa and then why why the new
york move
uh so creative dude i get it like the
creative like juices out there yeah so
my girl's from new york well she's not
from new york but she lives in new york
um and when we met she also has a
connection to thailand so we were both
over in thailand and uh the pandemic
happened
and so that's where we were kind of like
okay are we going to lock down here
we're going to lock down in new york and
we decided to lock down in thailand so
of course when we were planning to come
back to the states that's where the
decision-making happened
where um
we just both decided that we'd want to
go to new york there's some even with
the fight like obviously fashion and
all that street wear stuff you're doing
new york's a mecca of that so it's la
but new york's definitely a mecca of
that but also as far as the fight game
goes
if you wanted to you could really
relocate your entire camp in new york i
mean there's some monster monster
coaches out there absolutely especially
in that area absolutely actually like as
soon as i go back next week i decided
that that's where i'll do my jujitsu
with marcelo garcia's do you know henzo
at all i don't know enzo oh man we
should we should call them together
while you're here cool yeah i'm i'm
definitely open to just like you know
training with the best michelle is
obviously you know one of the best to
ever do it but and there's nothing like
kenzo man cool
i'm not opposed to to training with the
best that there is
so uh
going over your last fight
um i
you know
it's your second win in a row so that's
a plus but i was talking to chappelle we
have a mutual friend chappelle lacy who
loves you told me to tell you what's up
he was going to be here shout out
chappelle shut up
he was going to be here but he's in
arizona for family stuff okay but um
you know i was talking to chappelle and
because you know he doesn't know ufc and
i'm like yeah you know khalil's fight
he's like i know man i fall involved so
he thinks you win i'm like yes he should
win this one and then uh both chappelle
and i were like and i go i think he's
retiring after this and chapelle's
i thought he talked about that i had
mentioned it in the past yeah that's
when i was in thailand so
man when i went over there
it was just it was such a i'd never
experienced a country like thailand and
i saw people just you know on busy roads
selling the cheapest cups of coffee and
street food and stuff
you know definitely struggling to make
ends meet but they were so happy really
so happy it's known as the land of
smiles and i know exactly why so
it's like living in that environment
and falling in love with the the people
and the culture
um you know like it kind of switched my
my perspective my perspective and my
daily outlook and i started thinking
like
man like back in america i'm just
striving for so much it's a wrap you
know i'm like i want a big car i want a
big house i want all this stuff and like
look at these people happier than i am
like out here selling you know what i
mean like
whatever it is that they want to sell
and so that's kind of where i
i decided like you know what maybe after
my last fight
that like you know i'll be done fighting
mma because i've always also wanted to
fight muay thai
like that's i just have a love and a
passion for muay thai so pretty good at
it yeah and i learned like
that's the first martial art that i ever
trained and
it's the the martial art that seems the
most like natural for me to like pick up
and one month of
training in thailand i put on the
performance against eric anders so like
that's just one month so i was like
i want to try to
train for a year and then like actually
fight in like a thai stadium where the
guys are betting and i do
my why crew and everything you know like
to honor the gym that i fight for so you
down that thai oil yeah exactly like
that's all i think the guys are the guys
are back there like talking just like
how we are before they fight too it's
it's so weird everybody's in the same
locker room warming up not even warming
up just like
yeah i'm going to warm up right now they
just get like you know rubbed down in
thai oil and then they're just like all
right we're going to go out and it's
it's just a whole different approach to
right yeah i thought i don't mean to
rupture i also think too it's like
in both senses like the fighting is you
know they start when they're kids like
some of those kids have i don't know a
thousand fights by the time they're 15.
yeah so it's like it's like ghosts
playing football or pick up basketball
they do muay thai but then also with the
perspective of you know the guy selling
coffee which did you try the coffee or a
coffee oh yeah amazing is it nice
all right i'd like to go there now too
far in flight but whatever um but with
the coffee it's like uh how happy you
see them it's all perspective right
ignorance is bliss because you grew up
in la in vegas they've been in new york
so it's like
i even if you move to thailand
and i'm not hating on you if you want to
move to thailand but because of the
perspective you have and the way you've
come up and what you know it's gonna be
tough to be as happy as that guy
who's taking a piss on the side of the
sidewalk absolutely absolutely um
so yeah it was it was a mixture of that
man like just kind of being in that in
that atmosphere seeing a whole different
approach to fighting and that's kind of
what brought up the the idea of
retirement but
during the pandemic and you know that
was just a lot of time to reflect right
in indoors internally if you didn't come
out a better person after this pandemic
yeah you wasted your life man yeah it
forced everybody and you're like me a
creative and then also like we go go go
and that pandemic it's forced officer to
shut down like all right what's
important and i realized me personally i
was like oh i i work too much i tore too
much man you're gonna be at home more
for the kids that's what you gotta do
yeah it was very similar and but for me
personally it was a thing of like
i just had this feeling like no i'm not
done and just you know just like i said
in my post-flight interview it's like
man i really think that like
i have a story that can be shared that
can help other people that were like me
that like literally had no idea
of any type of direction on where they
wanted to go what they wanted to be or
any even like care to wake up in the
morning the next day you know what i
mean
i look at you almost like a superhero
where you have this responsibility with
great power comes great responsibility
spider-man quote but um because of your
background because what you represent
to me and that's why i told chipago it'd
be a shame if he was done chipotle's
like really and he knows like i like
when guys retire and move on to
something else like what i did i love
when guys have a career
even bigger after the ufc which you're
gonna have i just told chapel i'm like
it'd be a shame if he stopped right now
he's still young he's still getting
better every fight people love to watch
him it's like his name's also never been
bigger so to walk away now i just don't
i'm i'll do what i'm down for whatever
you want to do i'll support whatever you
want but you just have so much more to
do and so many more young kids who are
like you that you can inspire and i
don't think they have a lot of role
models like that if that makes sense
same same and that's that's a part of
of um
of
yeah like why why i chose to come back
and
it would be a shame and i think you
mentioned like something along the lines
of like being like a superhero in a
sense and
when i was in thailand that's when i
actually started writing a story about a
superhero a black superhero named super
champ so it's like resembles me but it's
not me but the story that i've tied into
it has a lot of similarities the
backgrounds the background you know what
i mean and the just like the emotional
response to life
and your background you're basically
bruce wayne you're batman right yeah
kind of not your parents weren't rich
yeah exactly so
um you know it's like
things like that like i think when i
when i'm done with fighting and i look
back i want to be able to see like the
the
the canvas that i pre that i painted
right i want to be able to look back and
say what did i create out of out of all
of this you know out of all of these
tools and these experiences
like what did i make out of it and one
of them is like yeah i don't personally
want to be the superhero because i'm
just like
you know a sensitive guy and i
react to a lot but if i could just
creative like if i can create one and
create a story about one that i would
still dream to be it would be beautiful
you know what i mean i love that with
your post-fight speech that has gone
viral everywhere
that was obviously an organic moment and
i i i don't know uh what journalist
asked the question but he was searching
for
felder
who it was paul felder yeah shout out to
paul feldman yeah seriously i know
that's paul felt i love paul i love paul
feldman he's great
crushing it too such a good analyst oh
yeah but um
you know i love you like you know kids
that were like you watching this at home
that have to trigger something because i
don't think the audience realizes if
you've been through a fight like when
you're done win or lose it's so
emotional it's like this roller coaster
and again win or lose there's a sense of
relief there's a sense of pride and then
you're also i remember win or lose
especially after a win if i would like
knock the gap in 47 seconds i was so
happy i as soon as i got to the back uh
where the curtains are i get on my hands
and knees i'm not a religious dude i
pray to whatever it was absolutely just
being like thank god i'm not hurt man
absolutely thank you for not letting me
get hurt i was so relieved and emotional
i cried damn near after every fight i'm
sensitive like you are so yeah for you
when paul felder asked that question
you know obviously you're high on
emotions but
you you've obviously you know you know
that you that this narrative right like
you know you have to tell this story and
that came out sore so organically and i
think that's why it resonates with
everybody because i do think there are a
lot of kids who you know don't come from
the best background or maybe they've
lost a parent or they have dreams to do
something else and you're the guy doing
it which gives them you know so much
more hope i would say yeah man that that
actually
you know sometimes as fighters i'm sure
you've had the experience where like
you're trying to visualize a win and
you're like what am i gonna say after
this and i didn't have any idea
of anything until the day of the fight i
was on the couch and i was like i need
to take a nap i had a lot of energy i
wanted to run
six miles you know like i had so much
energy and i was like you know what i
don't want to burn out let me just take
a nap yeah so as i'm taking a nap and my
heart's just pounding and
just like dealing with like just the
pressure of fight day um it's not the
worst by the way no nothing hanging
around the day of the fight and you're
hanging in the hotel yeah and you know
you got to fight this monster at 7 p.m
exactly you're literally just time in
the day look at the clock all right they
told me it'd be right at four okay
it's 7 a.m
and and so i started asking myself like
why do i do this
i'm like why every time i ask i'm i'm
like why why why do i do this i'm going
outside i went outside woke up from the
nap i'm pacing around i'm asking myself
like man why am i doing this and that's
when it came
for those for those other kids just for
for telling my story for
for to for showing not even necessarily
telling the story but for like
letting people know like who i am and
what i'm about and like
and
you know when i get interviewed and
media it's like they see me as just this
ufc fighter that's you know vicious in
the cage and i'm just like when i go
back and read it i'm like yeah but you
missed it a huge part man you missed the
biggest part of it all yep and so that's
kind of when i started thinking so the
for from that moment on the rest of the
day i was just
in the why like okay why okay yeah
you're right yeah that is why that's a
good because you're dad because your mom
because you know how they raised you and
what you went through and all the weight
you lost and the sacrifice and the blood
just everything started to hit me at
once and then that's when just my focus
was like
like laser like nothing in the world
could touch me at that moment i love it
as soon as i got it i just i felt like i
had this like supercharged powered like
unstoppable what what a great reason of
why you got an answer and i don't mean
to put more pressure on you but when i
was talking to chappelle about it you
know i told him this i said he almost
can't stop he owes it to those kids to
keep going through this and be a
a role model yeah it's it you know it's
stuff the same puts pressure on you
which you're fine with pressure it's
what you signed up for it's like you owe
it to these other kids who need that
role model they're not getting it you're
not getting hollywood you're not getting
it you know in other sports really
because they're not telling their story
hollywood nobody can relate to but you
they can you're touchable they can see
it you know yeah for sure and i think
i think one thing that that that stands
out and it's down to me today on the
plane is
i don't necessarily want to like inspire
everybody to become a fighter because i
know that this isn't all that i'm going
to be
you know like i just acted in my first
movie you know i'm like doing stuff with
a brand
uh all these things that i'm like i just
want to be able to
live freely and almost like just be an
example if nothing else but but fighting
is that pathway gives you the platform
that's going to be able to branch off to
all that other stuff you can yeah
think it's such a small sliver of what
you do but it gives you this huge
platform to inspire all these other kids
yeah and it it gave me my health back
right like my health and just like
courage to take on life you know and and
things like that so like yeah yeah we're
going to get to that whole weight loss
thing speaking of weight loss um
let me feed you yeah let's do this yeah
let's do it
let's take a little break from chatting
with my brother from another mother
khalil roundtree on this episode of food
truck diaries cause fellas i'm out there
on the streets i'm getting coffee i'm
touring all around i'll be in chicago
this weekend and i will bet my bottom
dollar when i meet a lot of you bros out
there you're losing your hair man you're
losing your hair and two out of three
men will experience some form of hair
loss by the time that they're 35 more
than 50 million bros in the u.s suffer
from male pattern baldness it ain't good
you're looking like george costanza out
there and my friends that keeps they got
you covered man keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
they're the only two fda approved
medications that can prevent hair loss
my friends that keeps offers both that's
right keeps offers a simple affordable
and stress-free way to keep your
freaking hair they have 24 7 care and
support all right it's low cost
treatments are just 10 buckaroos a month
to keep your hair man keeps offers
generic versions of the two fda approved
medications to prevent hair loss
treatment plans are affordable typically
half the cost of pharmacy prices so what
are you doing man safe here save your
money as well all right remember
prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so you need to act right
now before you straight up bald when it
comes to your hair save more spend less
if you're ready to take action prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com
shobb s-e-h-a-u-b to receive your first
month of treatment for free that's keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com shobb to get your
first month free keeps.com
[Music]
how you doing boss
thanks for doing this man appreciate you
of course um
look at the menu i will keep it
carnivore i will do the uh the smash
burger the double patty just no bun you
got it that's it no fries either for me
yep i want the same exact thing you got
it man same exact thing but can i get a
double we got you guys give me about a
few minutes and i'll knock it out for
you guys but you want fries can you
throw a side of fries please
thank you awesome thank you sir
[Music]
everything
all right my man let's let's feed you
how uh how's the diet bit are you one of
those guys that gets done fighting
you're pretty crazy on the diet or does
the old school fat kid jeans and you
still you still kind of well i got the
fries
i think i think that's the part that is
never going to go away is i'm always
going to love french fries like i just
have
a passion for freshmen
but in the past i would go ham like
pancakes donuts sugar but you know like
the past two camps i've i've kept it you
know pretty clean and i think this camp
i really plan to keep it clean do you
have to like really watch what you eat
because you have those
i don't think because you have great
genetics but so but if you go kind of
wild out do you blow up only if i'm not
working out yeah like if i'm still
training then it's almost like
you know i can eat whatever i want but
if i'm not you know if i'm not training
then
i definitely have to keep it clean then
i think that's where it gets dicey for a
lot of guys when they retire they eat
like they were when they were fighting
but they forget they're not working out
anymore yeah and then they really
balloon up and not even like half as
hard right
quarters
so going back
how old were you when you were at your
heaviest
uh 19 90 so now i mean not that young
2019 how we're talking 300 even or what
are we talking about 305 is like what i
remember seeing on the scale
like days before i joined the the gym at
the mma or at vanderlace because
at that time when i was finding out
about mma we'd watch fights and it was
like oh in this corner weight class you
know i was learning about weight classes
and all of that
so i remember stepping on the scale and
seeing 305 and seeing that there was no
weight class for someone who was 300 or
not super heavyweight weight class you
know in the ufc at the time so
um yeah i was 19
305 on the scales and and what but what
inspired the the mma route the fighting
route so
i think it had a lot to do with
my
background in like hardcore music and
heavy like heavy metal and punk rock
just like a heavier like aggressive
music yeah um i found a lot of refuge in
like the shows and the concerts in the
mosh pits yeah
the chaos yeah like i could never go and
pick a fight with somebody and i didn't
like confrontation you know one-on-one
but
the first time i went to like a punk
rock show
uh it was it was wild and i saw people
just like screaming and jumping and
jumping off the stage and stepping on
each other's heads and i was just like
ah and i finally tried it and it was
just such this release of
all of this stuff that i had you know
what i mean
yeah just everything built up and that
was like my place where i felt like i
could set like i can let it free and
isn't that weird that that like you
found comfort in that chaos even though
it's it is controlled chaos and
chappelle tells me all the time but
again when you talk about chappelle lacy
same thing he was a kid who came from
you know pretty rough uh childhood and
then he found the same kind of outlet
with punt rock punk rock music and you
know doing these mosh bits stuff like
that my only caveat with that is both
you guys like
you know you don't see a lot of black
guys in the mosh pit you know what i'm
saying like it's a pretty white thing
like those those punk rock concerts
you're going to so did you feel like an
outcast during that or
it didn't matter dude i felt like an
outcast my whole life so yeah i still do
like my
when after my father died i saw i was
born here in l.a after my father died
howard it was only two
so like my mom
at the time so she had three boys right
and my grandmother was dying she who
lived in vegas so we went out there to
take care of her
and so
when we decided that my mom decided that
this is where we're gonna live in las
vegas
she made sure that
with whatever money she had that she got
us in like a nice neighborhood
so
my brothers were like more active guys
they played sports you know they were
like lighter none of my brothers none of
us look alike the lighter skin kind of
pretty boy guys got all the girls all
this stuff but my dad i have a separate
dad but he was a bigger guy so as i grew
i just like started to blow up and be
chubby and face was your dad chubby uh
yeah it was like 3 40 6 66
like big big yeah big dude
yeah for sure big boy yeah security
right um so just like you know that that
whole process i just i don't know i i my
brothers were athletes i didn't want to
be an athlete um i like music and of all
sorts
and so like
i just was really struggling to find
like where do i fit in and then like you
know i went through a phase of when i
started learning heavier music like i
was very
you know similar to some people where
like i liked
the more like punk rock look or like you
know all black clothing and chains and
spikes and like i just felt like that
was kind of my protective
you know what i mean like barry or
because i was sensitive and like so yeah
it was just kind of like
outcasted so just having that
those layers around me as a kid is kind
of what drew me to the music and then
the aggression in the music and the mma
is kind of what like
meshed together and i was like ah there
there might be a place for me in in this
you know and then the love for music
comes from your pops was he had
something to do with boy is it boy's
demand yeah so i think i think it has a
lot to do with
like as a kid you know knowing
before i even knew what like death was
and all that i do remember i'd walk down
the hallways and i'd see
platinum and gold records from new
edition and boyce to men and and and
morris day and everything with my name
on it and which is also my dad's name
so just those like subconscious memories
of seeing like platinum and gold records
in the house and seeing my dad in like a
super fly suit posing with you know
prince and you know just so many people
and like what did your dad do exactly
the music for boys too man he was like
the road manager oh wow
um but it was a little bit more than
that from
the stories that i've heard like
they slept on the couch and you know it
was more like a father figure you know
what i mean yeah and so
yeah like a protector and like kind of
like their guidance because being young
boys on the road
you know like they need somebody who's
kind of like a dad right like these guys
were young man your dad's sick sicks big
dudes you know so he was like kind of
savvy yeah so in charge of just kind of
guiding them and helping them make you
know decisions and stuff like that and
did your father pass away on the road
with them yeah
no it's okay
it's the story so
my dad was on tour with boys to men the
tour was boyce man m.c hammer no phantom
1992.
um
in short they had you know they had
their concert their show and um
after the show while my father was in a
hotel there was two guys that had
planned to rob him and like break in and
rob because my dad you know he liked to
wear jewelry and very nice guy like you
know clean cut what city is this uh
chicago
so some stuff happens you know like they
disturb the room he comes out
fight breaks out uh one of the guys had
a gun
you know they're getting to fight a
tussle um
and it resulted in them shooting my dad
and killing him on the spot so senseless
so like
yeah so there's a bunch of other stuff
where like the guy only got like you
know six years in prison for it and
you know they're just
there was just so much like weird stuff
to it and i all the stories that i heard
from everyone who knew my father was
like how amazing of a person he was i
bet and how he was like your dad bought
me my first car he took me here he
introduced me to this and he bought me
my first suit and just so many good
things and as a kid i'm like i got none
of that that's such a bad you know what
i mean like but you but you did get some
of that you know what i'm saying like
you're such a good person you're such a
good human being especially with the
background that you have
a lot of that's in your dna man that's
from your pops you know even though he's
not here yeah thank you yeah i
appreciate that
that's really cool man it's obviously
it's a terrible terrible tragedy but
your dad would be so proud and you know
that yeah yeah that'd be
that means a lot and i think so like
just how i processed all the information
of all of that i think is what caused
this like anger within me
you know and like this anger assuming
you talk to a therapist or anything like
that just held everything in yeah i
always like especially as a kid i held
everything in you know the quiet guy shy
you know i was
like i think my mom was like the closest
to me because both of my brothers were
just happy to go outside and be playing
sports yeah you know what i mean on that
outlet i was more like i like to stay at
home and
lock myself in my room and
teach myself how to play music yep or
i've made friends with some of the kids
in the neighborhood who skateboarded yup
and
things like that and so i just took a
different route like culturally yeah you
know make sense
so when
obviously you see the aggression and the
the mosh bit stuff like that and at what
point were you like all right i need to
lose weight so i can actually compete as
a and
initially when you're like right you're
you know you're sitting on the couch 200
pounds you have titties right you're
like all right i want to was it like i
want to fight in ufc
no so you just want to get like
one step at a time
it's always been
i remember
so after high school
i went through
for my my experience of high school was
you know like i said feeling out of
place
kind of feeling bullied a little bit not
really knowing where do i fit in in the
world where do i fit in
in this like you know in school
so i knew i wasn't going to go to
college because i didn't want to
have the same experience in in the same
place
so
some of my friends who were successful
at the music that they played
um they got a record deal
and they were like okay we're going to
go on tour do you want to come with us
and sell merch and i was like they're
like we get to travel every day we get
to go around the world and
you know the label will pay you daily
just for being with us you know
and you can make tips so they like they
pitch me this idea of like traveling and
being at shows every day
for two and a half months at a time
which is a priceless kind of life lesson
too yeah especially what you're doing
now yeah so fresh out of high school
that's what i chose to do
and
there was a moment where so on the road
it was like
cigarettes
alcohol
fast food gas station food
you know no working out like i'm just
sitting at a table all day selling
t-shirts how do i pass time
just smoking you know soda whatever
so
a few years of that
um
stacked on to like just the lifestyle i
had already been living like the health
you know my lifestyle was unhealthy
um
there was a point where i was 19 and
we were on a break from tour
and i'm just like i had a heart scare
oh damn yeah from just everything that
i bet what's going on you know
i'm trying to fall asleep and i just
feel
it felt like my heart was struggling to
just like stay out like to stay around
and it
scared me
so
um not not too long after that we went
on our next tour which was my last and
on the road there's a bunch of time to
think
and i started like looking at everything
differently and i'm like these guys are
doing something that they love to do
correct they're getting all this
acknowledgement they're playing stages
every night people are lining up to meet
them in line
and like
they're living the dream and we're all
the same age and i'm like and i'm just
some extra guy that like
is helping them sell their t-shirts you
know
and so
um
just like reflecting i'm like i have to
do something different like and that
heart scare
really messed me up thank god you know
what i mean so like i was just like i
think
the number one thing that i'm gonna do
when i get back home is i'm gonna
like join a gym or lose weight or
something and so um
uh
yeah i had like
i on that break and around the heart
scares when i saw mma with my brother he
kind of introduced me to what it is
yeah he was watching the ultimate
fighter what season uh the rampage
season when you tore down the door oh
wow that was my season yeah oh
yeah you were on that season that was so
i loved
yeah go on
so biggest season ever well here's
here's why i said it that way because
when i saw him tear down the door i saw
the aggression
all the aggression and i think the door
was fake but yeah i hear you
and that's when i was like you know what
i feel like i can be
in the group of these people like i just
feel like i belong yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like these guys there's a part of
them that's angry there's a part of them
that's badass you know and i was like
this could be sick so i i told the guys
on the tour
and i was like hey this might be my last
tour i don't think i'm gonna come back
again like i think i want to work out
get in shape and like potentially like
fight yeah and they were like yeah yeah
good luck with that and then they're
showing me photos like oh who like this
guy showed me bobcat photos like
she's worked there
like this like the the phone was being
passed around the the van like pops
in 10 years you know
and i'm like oh yeah like literally i
know you beat the [ __ ] up
you know like you
really
like i don't even know what they googled
to even like get a picture of bob's
house especially no one knew about mma
so massive yeah so big huge no one knew
about mma back then in my circle of
friends so like what did they google oh
yeah i wonder what they did so um that's
so funny so yeah that was that was my
last tour and then when i got back my
brother and i uh started watching more
videos he showed me vanderle silva he's
like look at this guy he's called the
axe murderer and i saw him and like he's
doing this yeah he's doing that and he's
like soccer kicking people and he's
doing all this crazy stuff and i was
like i want to fight like him and then
lo and behold his gym was in las vegas
before we get back to the show with my
boy khalil rountree on this episode of
food truck diary listen we all dads out
there the one thing you know you're
getting older you got kids the one thing
you care about not as much as your kids
but damn close is your lawn there ain't
nothing like a green lawn man it's hard
to imagine spring is almost here it's
popping around here in l.a it's getting
hot man we're so close to feeling that
soft grass on our feet the kids are
playing on it but you need to get your
lawn right and thankfully sunday get
your lawn growing and helps keep it
healthy all season long your boy gets
the greenest lawn you've ever seen looks
like a golf course thanks to my friends
at sunday all right and you're worried
about all the chemicals you're using to
keep your yard looking fly traditional
lawn care lays down 90 million pounds of
pesticides each year save it dude sunday
is different they're on a mission to
change how people care for their yards
all right sunday is so different now you
don't have to choose between having a
beautiful yard and keeping your family
out of harm's way we got you man sunday
can help you grow a beautiful lawn that
all your neighbors will be jealous of
without the guesswork or the nasty
chemicals all right just attach the
ready to use pouch to a garden hose and
spray away takes less than 15 minutes
you got 15 minutes for a green lawn all
you dads out there i think you do man
best of all this stuff really works
sunday's offering you guys who are
watching this episode of food truck
diaries khalil roundtree they're
offering 20 off man 20 off full season
plants are just 129 bucks you can get 20
off at checkout when you visit
getsunday.com
shop20 that's 20 off your custom planet
getsunday.com20
get your lawn green let's get back to
the program
now let me tell the viewers some about
this though that that gym vanderlei
silva's gym in vegas
that gym especially back then when he
went there was notoriously known as like
a tough
gym like it's not like now when guys
take care of each other like a lot of
people were scared to go in there
because you go in there and get knocked
out you know it's known as like a rough
rough dream kind of like you know
vanilla comes through the old shoebox
stays in brazil like
in training completely different now now
it's more of a professional approach but
vanderlei silva's approach of the game
his nickname is the axe murder right so
his whole thing was in training they
would literally try to knock each other
out yeah like it was so you not only did
you you know at 300 pounds decide to
sign up for a gym but you signed up for
the roughest toughest gym in all of the
nation absolutely which is insane and so
how did it go there
so the first
um you know when when on the like we
watch all his videos
and when they introduce him
i don't know if they still do it but
like bruce buffer like this fighter
specializes in muay thai and jiu jitsu
and so i started asking my brother hey
what's the difference like what's muay
thai and what's jiu jitsu he's like muay
thai is more like the punching in the
kicking
like that's what i want to learn
so
when we went to sign up and they gave us
like the membership
like plan like what do you want to sign
up for
i didn't have the money to do the full
package
so if i was going to do this for both of
us yeah so i paid for my time
um
that's what like so that was my first my
first class and so
um i did the class and
after the trainer was like hey have you
done this before i'm like no i've never
he's like i think you have like a
talent he's like you should come back
such a long ways with a young mind a
young mind who has no idea who's never
really been like
you know like accepted in sports or
whatever and i never even wanted to play
sports or never even yeah so whatever he
he's like yeah come back um tomorrow
whatever eleven o'clock
that's so such a long ways yeah that
made me really happy and i'm like wow
i'm welcome at this place and so um
that's just kind of how everything
kick-started yep yeah put the fire
underneath you did you ever get to spar
with the vandalized silver oh yeah
oh yeah so i mean literally the scariest
guy
in training scariest guy of all time as
much
or him or uh verdum as my
training
as my skills got better
um is when they started like throwing me
in and so when i was on the journey of
losing 100 pounds i had already sparred
vanderlei maybe like two or three times
before my first amateur fight
and it was oh yeah
i mean i mean like you said it's it's
it's one of those gyms where
like i know he wasn't purposely trying
to kill me but there is really no limit
as to how far the sparring goes
it's also to his defense is all he knows
yeah it's always his perspective he's
like this is what i did it's like are
you ready are you ready okay go and if
you're not ready you shouldn't be in
here exactly and that's what
most people who like that's the message
that was given hey if you like if you're
stepping on the mat you're you'll be
ready to go you got to be ready to go so
um yeah i didn't really know what i was
doing um but i was a big guy and he saw
that i had heart that you know
and so
yeah i took my beatings pretty early and
then uh he kept going back
yeah and he was so supportive man and
like my first amateur fight he was there
my first amateur title fight he was
there and held my hand the legend put
them out well you know and he always
just had nothing but good things to say
about me and so there was just that time
where like van der ley silva like giving
me this acknowledgement and being there
and supporting me and kind of lifting me
up was just it was a huge
a huge thing and so yeah we we had a lot
of uh a lot of good sparring matches i
bet man i uh none of which i
won you know like dude
yeah yeah completely it's one of those
things he's so scary and hits so hard
and skills has no like stop buttons no
there's no like you know cars have like
different gears like second third or
fourth there he skips that it's first or
fifth yeah and it's usually fifth all
the time it's so intense
you came up and just i mean just the
roughest way possible but i'll tell the
story about khalil
so i uh when i was fighting ufc
when i moved to l.a my my camp consisted
of like henry gracie and rain i do my
wrestling and i do all my sparring and
uh stand up at black house and black
cast i don't know if it's still there
they made a new one they made new ones
but black house was a gym where anderson
silva was there ed suarez was one of the
owners and also the manager of big nogg
anderson silva any brazilian fighter he
represented him so they had there at the
gym i would train with anderson silva
leona machida
uh verdoom would come sometimes uh ishii
it was just a room full of killers
killers volkov from bellator coming
there where i would spar with him all
the time mont and pat cummings sponsors
so i'm getting ready i'm in camp and
i've never met khalil before and me and
anderson sparred anderson jumps out and
uh cleo gets in i've never seen him but
he's in good shape at this time in my
head i'm i'm thinking i was like so you
know some young kid or whatever i you
know i was pretty well known in the ufc
in my head i'm like some young kid i
should probably take it easy on
something like that and uh anderson uh
doesn't say anything he just goes good
luck and i'm like all right whatever
dude and i go and have you ever seen me
and khalil sparring have you ever seen
uh
in rush hour where chris tucker is about
to fight all those asian breeds and he
kicks in the face he's like all right
which one he all kicked me
dude i got lit up like a christmas tree
because i i didn't know he was that good
and the round gets done i'm like jesus
chris someone should give me a heads up
and as soon as he you know that gentle
high voice he's very good he very good
everything you used to be fat boy you
sweet fat boy i'm like okay you know and
that's how i was introduced to i'm like
dude his stand-up's ridiculous and then
cheetah is like yeah he gives me fritz
man i'm like what them why the [ __ ] is
it in the ufc and they're like he'll get
there give it time he'll get there and i
just remember you're just such this
monster
and then your story's so crazy because
uh i think machida was telling me too he
was telling me he was yeah he used to
sell fight gear and then at the otm shop
i'm like really he's like he's fight
self fighting nice hair with us i was
like that is [ __ ] insane yeah that
that's what got me my opportunity to
come out to cali so
um
the job i used to have a job at jimmy
john's before
in between tours
just always trying to find a way to just
like make a few bucks so my best friend
uh he was the manager at jimmy john's
and he hired all of our all of his best
friends so it was like the best work
environment ever
and so um
yeah i was like making sandwiches and
training at the time and then um
i got offered a job at uh otm fight
shops which used to be such a big deal
like now you're short of gear online
yeah but there used to be like only one
like major fight shop otm was like the
shop yeah the shop like they made
all the gear all of the gear yes they're
like the original fight shop right the
best
so scotty um he had like hit like him
and ryan had a bunch of stores they had
one in vegas and then they had a few
here in cali
and at the time when i was working uh
there i was also
fighting as an amateur so um
with people within like the local
community noticed me and then when they
found out that i worked at otm too it
kind of like kind of helped in a way
because then they could come in and talk
and then i could go into other gyms and
be like hey what do you guys need so um
i made some pretty good changes there
and like scotty came to me one day he's
like hey man like the numbers are super
good at this store it hasn't been like
this in forever he's like would you be
willing to come out to cali and do the
same thing for the south bay store
and i was like yeah absolutely he's like
if you want he's like i know you live
here in vegas he's like but i can get
you set up to train at black house i
know the guys over there
the store is not too far from the gym so
you can
you know still commute to the gym and
work every day and at the time like you
come to south bay it's one of the
reasons i came out here it was like the
hotbed for mma i'm talking
killers everywhere everything you could
you'd walk in the gym and you're getting
like the best work you've ever seen it
was like the golden age of fighting it
really was ridiculous and so yeah that's
that's uh
yeah i was working at the fight shop and
then i wasn't even professional yet i
didn't have my first pro fight until
maybe close to the time that you and i
sparred you were ready to go
you were ready to go yeah and then uh
being at black house you would you'd us
i assume you'd spar with anderson and
machida and all the boys all the time i
met anderson at black house uh we had
our first sparring session it was like a
dream come true i'd always wanted to
meet anderson silva
and then he's like hey like he's the
nice guy in the world so nice and he's
like i like your energy like yep i'm
getting ready to fight nick diaz come
come to my camp and i was like what yeah
come to my camp you come and i was like
okay
so i stayed uh i was when i was living
in cali already so um yeah i did i did
camp with him for the nick ds fight i'm
sure you learned a ton from that so much
and the training was like training that
i've never seen before he had multiple
coaches and he would do you know
footwork stuff and reaction and i was
like this is amazing you got your
master's degree in like how to run a
camp yeah and his facility was just top
notch right the muay thai college so
um
yeah that like that was also a part that
was like also life-changing because
if it weren't for that camp like that's
where we really like made a strong
connection and then after being with him
for that is when
he then started to like consider me like
a little brother you know and aft
actually before we left to vegas
he like sat me down during one of his
interviews and he's like hey come on sit
here and i was like okay and so i'm just
kind of sitting there and he like fully
endorsed me he's like this guy's going
to be a champion yeah
yeah yeah
even with me he was like you too relax
he good he good you too relaxed i'm like
[ __ ] tell me before we go dude i
didn't know
so
it's i just it started to give me more
and more hope because like i said like
from going to losing weight to then
fighting amateur
then getting a job to just work in the
fight shop you know i always had like
aspirations once i started fighting to
be a professional or to be at the
highest level but
i was still working there it was like
you know like my my vision was happening
kind of to month yeah it takes a while i
never said i'm going to be the champion
this is what i want and this is where
i'm headed but i i think and the same
thing happened for me uh with gsp i went
to his camp and i also went to vitor
belfort's camp and like
being around those guys what you realize
is yeah they're at the pinnacle of the
ufc and they're the face of ufc and
they're these world-class athletes and
world champions and they're so freaking
you know famous but
i think once you're around somebody for
that long that type of camp and you see
the way it's structured you just
download so much data but then you also
realize like oh they're just normal
they're like me they have the same
issues they have the you know they go
through the same ups and downs as i do
and you're like oh they're just normal
and for me it like you know if you're a
fan of batman it's like you see him
without the suit and like oh he's a
normal ass dude dude yeah like i can do
this so i think once you're around it
makes you realize like oh i could do
this if they can do it i can do it yeah
it makes it way more tangible yep you
know what i mean and so
um
yeah i think
i think
i'm
there was just a point
in all of this i think up until up until
now
i've kind of just been
not really like two feet in you know
i've just i've just been like let me
tell okay you know so much confidence
has come up
though too you know which i think
a lot of fighters you know and i
interview fires all the time around my
time but a lot of it is they don't have
anything else to do so they have to be
two-footed a a blessing and a curse for
you and the same thing with me is i was
also one foot in one foot out because i
want to do all this other stuff but the
problem is when you're fighting the ufc
at that level you if you're not two feet
in you're not gonna be around long man
there's killers out there dude you know
this yeah you know so it's like again
it's a double-edged sword it's like
thank god you have all these other
interests where you're gonna make a
beautiful living when you're done but
same time if you don't water the grass
over here it's gonna get dicey man yeah
you know and there's nothing worse than
like
being
half in half out when you got another
killer in front of you that's like
hungry who's all ready to eat yeah right
like that's a very similar situation for
like that johnny walker fight like i
just remember there was just so much
going on and i was just so focused on
like
just
the wrong things and i remember showing
up to fight week and doing everything
and i just wasn't fully there i'd
emotionally mentally i would love if
they gave you that fight now i think you
beat the [ __ ] out
it'd be interesting on johnny at all i
just yeah johnny great guy great monster
you know he
it's been tough right it's tough after
that fight he even came up to me in the
locker room afterward and he's like
hey man like i'm sorry to bother you i
just i need to ask you a question i was
like what he's like did someone die in
your family or something crazy because
he's like you just don't look like
yourself this is good he's like this
whole week yeah he's like i wanted to
ask you before we even fought so like
he's like i felt like i didn't want to
overstep the boundaries but like you
know like is everything all right with
you and i was just like
it's like nah man i was like
just go like you know like this is the
first time i've ever been ko'd yeah you
know there's nothing worse like you're
almost like hanging around like i
appreciate it yeah it's also
when the emotion settled i appreciated
it for sure you know it shows what kind
of guy he is yeah yeah solid so
um yeah you gotta gotta be all in and i
think i've gotten to a point now too
where i just
i've just matured a lot man you know i
can i
i
have an idea of
what type of
like man i want to be yeah you know what
type of
story i want to tell or or just like
picture that i want to paint and i also
think you're you're better at managing
where you can still do this stuff you
want to do with the fashion line all
that other stuff you want to do in your
building you can still be all in you
know like it's more about managing did
you get older experience that stuff
comes yeah absolutely so uh we haven't
talked much fighting you know again this
is what why won't you on the show you
know but um when it comes to fighting
you know you've won your last two fights
that last one was vicious dude it was
like you're back in the mosh pit days
yeah you're watching pride videos with
your brother i don't think i've seen a
dude
go for those old school pride kicks in a
hot second man you just unleash the fury
on that poor kid i think so that's the
second time
that i've ever done a body kick while
the guy was down
and i think that also comes from like
van der ley
like watching him and just like you know
there's just something inside of some
fighters that just when you unleash a
certain fighting spirit you like you
never know what's going to come out of
it and so um
yeah i think it was
it was just
me just expressing like who i am and
what i'm capable of yeah
it definitely felt good um
you know i think
what felt bad what felt the best is the
win you know some sometimes
not all the time sometimes
like
i don't want to fight you know like
you know what i mean
like sometimes like i don't want to
fight and i don't know someday i'm like
is there i hate to be shitty yeah anyway
we could do this tomorrow yeah i'm down
to do it tomorrow i just don't feel like
doing it right now at 8pm yeah like it
doesn't matter dude you're an elephant
in the circus circus goes live at eight
i'm like i get that if i can do it
tomorrow i guarantee i win you making it
tonight it ain't gonna end well man it
goes it's a weird thing it goes to show
like i think as fighters we should
definitely get more respect because like
it goes to show that we'd show up and we
have to do what we have to do regardless
of how we feel correct you know what i
mean like and
no matter what like
if you have one match up and then you do
the same exact match-up the next day you
never know how it's going to go and like
you know like some days you wake up and
you know that you just feel like [ __ ]
yeah and you can't do anything about it
but but people at home watch this even
if you've never fought and still cage
your underwear you know
think about it when you're doing
whatever job you have you're nine to
five let's say you're a starbucks
employee i don't give a hell what it is
some days you wake up you just don't
feel like doing it same with fighters
same with football players soccer
players basketball we're human sometimes
you wake up like i don't want to do it
today
but on my [ __ ] main event on a
pay-per-view yeah i have no choice and i
have to do it to the greatest of my
abilities yeah otherwise i lose
unconsciousness i get knocked down in
front of millions of people it's very
embarrassing so oh and i get half my pay
half the pay holler and now with in the
recent days like
just
endless
pointless social media like [ __ ]
that if you're a human and you like to
use your phone and you like to use
social media you want to subscribe to
social media yeah
oh that's why you got knocked out yeah
okay
and even if you just pass on like you
still gotta read it and sometimes it's
like [ __ ] it's annoying and you just
wanna throw everything away so there's
just a lot to come with it but like we
do have to learn how to control
our emotions and still like kind of
deliver on on
you know what we've been training it's
one of the toughest jobs in the world
man yeah jobs in the world before we get
you out of here i gotta my boy uh george
would kill me if i didn't bring this up
there's a a young man he's out of
chicago he's a suburb of chicago he
actually works for a thick boy now but
uh at the time he did not he's this
young kid and uh he comes from a family
of addiction he didn't have a lot going
on i do a show called uh king the sting
in the wing with crystalline and theo
van and fans call in they call in you
know the you know king or sting it
whatever burgers or whatever and we
you know rip off that make jokes a
comedy show and so this kid calls in and
he's uh what like 400 pounds
little force no fours you know he's 400
pounds and uh not a fun 400 pounds right
so uh he gets on there he's like hey i'm
the biggest fan man he's like chop him
i'm a thick boy he's like flex and you
know and he's like i love khalil you
know i love his story blah blah blah
he's like i'm trying to get down to 190.
and you know my head i'm like good luck
my man you know it's like okay
but uh i challenge him i got tell you
what dude if you get down to 190 and i
go you're brown on planets no never you
ever stay at hotels no never tell you
what man you get down to 190 you don't
even get down to 200 which i didn't
think would ever happen you get down to
200 i will fly you out to la and put you
on the show and put you in a hotel
right say less i'm going to do it we get
off you know show ends i'm like there's
no way this kid's gonna lose freaking
whatever 200 pounds
fast forward a year later like i don't
know six months ago what was it six
months ago he's lost cereal gum's worth
of weight yeah he's down he's he's down
to 190 now he's down to 190. he's filmed
a video and he's like what's up job i
told you i didn't do it i'm like holy
[ __ ]
dude i'm like well man of my word i'll
connect you with the team we're gonna
fly ahead and put him on the show so we
put him on the show he's the sweetest
kid you've ever met he's like your
biggest fan like his north star
so you know he hasn't with his lifestyle
and taking care of his family and all
the addiction stuff he has every reason
to be just you know a terrible human
being but he is the sweetest kid you've
ever met
so he comes here i meet him we hit it
off right away and i go uh hey man uh
next week i'm playing in san antonio i'm
doing one of the biggest venues i've
ever done the 18th arena
where the spurs are at i said uh you
should come because he loves comedy like
he's balls deep in comedy mma he's like
us and he goes uh i go i'd love for you
to come to the show he's like oh man say
less i'm like right this way i'm gonna
fly you to san antonio and i'll put you
up at my favorite hotel because never
stay at hotels
so um
hotel emma in san antonio is there's
only one of them
you know i've stayed in a million hotels
it's the best hotel on the goddamn
planet it's so unique it's so well done
they have great coffee like everything's
detailed it's like kind of steampunk
kind of
vibes it's so dope
so i uh connect with the manager
i tell him the kid's story he goes you
know what we're gonna not only we're
gonna cover his hotel but we're gonna
give them our master suite that we save
for like celebrities like what he's like
it's honest man this is a great story so
george flies out we have a camera crew
with him and he gets in the hotel and
he's you know he's just freaking out
he's jumping in the pool this kid has
confidence he's in the pool with his
flats
comes to the show
and i have him with me the whole time i
bring him on stage i tell everybody a
story starts tearing up but he's your
biggest fan dude he loves you and this
is one of the reasons that i want to
talk to you
in front on there put a little pressure
on you because what you're doing
is more than about you you know what i'm
saying like your journey and what you've
gone through with your father and losing
you know this weight and you know it's
it's no mistake you had influences like
van der ley silva and freaking anderson
silva you know what i'm saying that
there's there's no mistake man it's
because you're a good person and
everybody who meets you sees the value
in you you know what i'm saying so
to me when
chappelle told me to retire i said he
can't
and i don't mean to put pressure on you
i said he can't i don't give [ __ ] if you
lose your next six yeah but it's not
about winner loss for you
your story is bigger than that so i want
to share that story about you with
george and we're going to get a way for
you guys to connect and then also that's
so cool yeah he's the best george shout
out to george he works for thick boy now
he's like one of our best employees he's
like a loyal reach out to me through
them yeah we'll connect you to something
connect yeah
yeah maybe facetime after this but then
also for coming on food truck we have a
segment i do now where i give uh all the
fighters a pair of shoes i'm a sneaker
head okay
i know i know i know you're a fashion
guy yourself
so
with this one i got dude so this is what
i got dude yours yours made me nervous
so usually it's pretty easy i know where
to go with it but with you my boy mike
and suplex philly shout out to suplex
philly the one who'll provide all the
shoes they're like the sneaker one-stop
shop super like philly any shoes you
need these guys to get it done okay
so i tell them your story they they know
you're like oh we love him like right so
but i was like he knows fashion dude so
we can't just give him like a random
pair of jordan something like that i go
we got to get him like a unique pair
because he's a unique dude there's not a
lot of cleos out there in the world so
we gotta get a pair that's rare because
you're a rare dude and these i don't
have these and we were the same size
shoe oh that says a lot dude and when
these showed up in my house i texted
them you have another pair
they don't because they're very hard to
find oh my fragments fragment joints
i might put them on now dude they are
filled
one of my favorite shoes ever and i
don't have them yo look at the back
they're so filthy man oh albert is gonna
hate so hard
that's my gift to you my man you're a
special dude these are special shoes wow
you're a special person yeah yeah i love
you man man yeah
for sure so i want to also share
something with you so
um around the realm of sneakers so um
i'm now the creative director of a
company called the label 318 they're out
of toronto
and what we do
is um
say
you like a jordan 3. um
but you want your own version of an
authentic real jordan 3.
or something yeah i i would
you know personally work with the people
of my
um you know of my choice to
pretty much
create their custom shoe oh dude so um i
do have a gift coming for you in the
mail that's why i texted you back your
shoe size uh that's uh you're the only
fighter
like
this isn't like uh we're not bombing
over like no just give me your shoe it's
part of the show
yeah i did um
yeah we designed a custom shoe for you
and it's made with a lot of uh
with a lot of intention and love and i
love it i can't admiration for
everything that you guys do here and
everything that you do yeah
i just want to share with you man like
honestly with
the things that we've talked about in my
journey and stuff like you have been one
of the biggest inspirations to me as far
as what you've done with
who you are what you did in the fighting
stuff and what you're doing now thanks
brother and
like just for our own personal you know
record
it's
there was a time where i saw your
podcast and you had favored me to lose
and because i had looked up to you so
much
like i had your birthday saved in my
phone which i thought was tomorrow and
happy birthday by the way yeah
i assume it's the johnny walker fight no
it was the kutilaba fight okay sorry
yeah you were like this one's going to
be the worst part it's the worst part of
my gig yeah he was like you know i just
remember i thought you were like one
foot in one foot you know what i'm
saying like i i hate making it it's okay
what happened is like i saw that and i
was like you know what [ __ ] this that
like hurt my feelings you should and i
apologize i look up to this guy but he
like it shows to me that he's like
betting against me so i would just like
[ __ ] brendan shaw makes sense like [ __ ]
this guy and i just started blocking a
bunch of people but
i just want to let you know that like
i'm unblocked yeah for sure no you're
you're on block but you're still blocked
because you're making pigs but no but
like i'll never pick against you ever
again i'm sorry
no um respect though like i really do
like everything that you do creatively
you know just it's it's sick man yeah i
love it man uh this might be my favorite
food truck we've ever done so i love the
[ __ ] eddie man and sky's the limit dude
i'm proud of you man thanks real
everybody
super thick from my wallet to my check i
don't want it if it's skinny but i need
it
[Music]
need a
the big thick
i need everything i get super thick boy